in the Donbas, in the city of Kostyantynivka, which
took place today, the attack was
just in the market, in the shops, in the
pharmacy.
we understand that they are doing
the same as before, when
certain
positive offensive steps of the
Ukrainian defense forces take place in that direction, the
Russians always hit
civilians and civilian objects,
where they get one or another type of
artillery rocket, we
know this direction very well  we
understand that they killed on purpose and killed
at the moment and the information I have
probably won't be very correct because the
relevant works are being carried out there 16
dead 20 wounded